[Music]
i played tomb raider and we shot it and
then we put it out uh on the show
and um i was so distracted when i was
playing tomb raider yes by the beauty of
the new lara croft i noticed you had a
little crush perhaps it wasn't just a
little crush i was i was uh totally
perving out the whole time
i didn't want to put it quite that way
that's what it was we just call it what
it was andy you saw it it was it was yes
he had a virtual boner yeah
[Applause]
i appreciate that
i can't tell if andy's a good wingman or
a bad wingman
you kept dying in the game because i was
getting distracted by your outfit and
all kinds of and then this it went
terribly let's just take a quick clip of
this is me playing with my good friend
aaron blair
to the right to the right dodge to the
right to the left
[Applause]
and that's the only way she dies yeah
that's not she died that way like that's
the only way you die is always pull
through the throat i got so upset like
the seventh time you died i threw the
controller down and i couldn't do it
anymore because i was in love with you
and i kept losing you over and over and
over again i spent a day in the adr
booth which is where you record like a
lot of the voice over work um
just dying just every way possible so
they make you do the vocal sounds of
dying so what does the director say the
director says here's this is the thing
about tomb raider she can be killed in
any way possible so they'll be like okay
just uh your face is on fire and you've
been stabbed a thousand times make that
noise and you're like what
what is that noise
so what is that noise what kind of
noises were you making
no wait a minute it's not that it's a
lot of variations on who boy
no
yeah sure sure i never heard you once
ago
that that's
that's someone having like too big a
bite of a burrito
they changed the look for lara croft
this time around did you approve she
went from shorts to long pants i
approved but i have to say i did think
that there would be a point in the game
where
she would have to
use her pants as a tourniquet and then
just rip them off and they'd be like
lacy hot pants i was like it's gonna
happen at some point you're gonna at
some point because the nerds that make
these games you know they've got that in
the back of their mind oh this can be a
tourniquet or this can be a bandage
zip line well these are the two this is
the old school i think we have there's
the old lara croft and the new lara
croft you've got the short pants the
long pants either way it works for me
that looks good i think she's good and
also i think long pants are more
practical if you're climbing around in
tune sure exactly